[Music]
and have you guys heard of foreign
accent syndrome I think that's what I
got that's you haven't have heard of it
what is it do you know it's where you
just apparently randomly develop a
foreign accent like just through like
trauma yes
yeah or I don't know the science behind
it but it's like not that you were
visiting somewhere and you like you know
picked up the accent like a study I knew
that all the time going on England or
somehow end up sounding more British you
come back and like an [ __ ] to your
friends like this guy thinks he's
[ __ ] I know it's like apparently when
it's just like suddenly triggers and now
you just have a foreign accent yeah yeah
yeah so yeah what they're saying is it's
a rare disorder where after brain damage
or having some trauma to the head
the the neurological pathways are like
disconnected and now all of a sudden
you're just kind of speaking and maybe
you came in to construct full sentences
and you're speaking of broken English
and also has a little bit of an accent I
remember I remember there was a British
lady who went in a coma and she woke up
with and she claims she has a Chinese
accent but it sounded like literally all
Chinese how does it pick up that accent
is that what region but how do you
determine do you get to choose which we
can accent front is it the last thing I
heard maybe he's like the one you're
most racist towards like it's Karma all
right well funny enough this is another
British lady she didn't get a Chinese
accent but she got this accent hi I'm
Emily
I'm from Bournemouth I'm I am 31 years
old and I have foreign accent syndrome
it all started what was a migraine
British actually it turned out to be a
sign of a stroke that I thought I was
admitted into hospital for three weeks
from that I actually couldn't speak at
all was discharged I'd still
it's very consistent no words came out
it sounds like Eastern European or
something but Russian can also like the
way she's speaking it could be like just
she has brain damages she just learned
her words well that was the beginning so
she got hurt I actually don't know how
she got hurt but basically when she did
get hurt her initial symptoms were she
couldn't speak at all
she like sure she couldn't activate her
own voice and she couldn't like speak
and after I think about two months she
came back to her but this time it came
back with an accident and then depending
on how tired she is and how like or
stressed she is her accident goes from
French to Italian to polish to Russian I
wonder which one her angry one is maybe
when she's nervous she's Russian cuz she
has like she's like on camera right now
so yeah this is the Russian hang it when
she's mad she turns polish or like
Italian she even throws the [ __ ]
hands out and [ __ ] hopefully like that
during sex let's take French then the
good now Russia particular sexy but yeah
so she thought and so now that she's
like has the foreign accent she also has
come across with something that she
never came across before her life which
was discrimination so walking by in
England they think she's some for yes
that people treat her differently now
she feel like certain people and not
everyone she says like most versatile is
really nice and inquisitive about her
axe and whatnot but some people start
you know berating her about going back
to her country and things like thanks
she sounds she sounds that one out of
four they're like get out of here
[ __ ] four wait what I like all this
southern comes on
daddy that's the racist guy across the
world my question is like do you have to
have had previous contact with that that
accent for your brain to Chinese they
the one that had that Asian accent never
left the country or left that her even
talent I don't think like how does your
movies movies you watch enough movies
maybe you pick up it's like that's what
if you've never liked you know you've
never this is like super isolated but
like you've never really heard that
accent and now like you have that trauma
do you still is it still possible to
speak now that you'd be impossible if
you never like heard it or anything like
that yeah cuz how would cause it's not
something you just have program in your
brain like accent how come boxers don't
have this that head trauma Mike Tyson
never has he started like that before
Japanese Mike Tyson accent that would be
so good
maybe it's different trauma because
every yeah every boxer would be like
speaking all kinds of crazy [ __ ] yeah
that will mean they definitely have a
slurred speech which is the beginning of
it yeah but I've maybe been you to get
punched in the head a couple more times
maybe mm-hmm have you heard about the
other brain damage thing where people
will wake up and it can speak like
languages that were gone like like
frickin Sumerian or like some ancient
language or like or like they never even
learned a language before and then they
can speak like they come out of
perfectly or whatever those I've seen
ones roars like they they speak Spanish
and they just became Expedia SH but they
didn't speak Spanish before that but I
guess a guy like hearing a lot they kind
of like put the words that - do they
lose original language like I think so
oh these so they lose the English but
they can speak the Spanish they
understand the illusio Senate and but
then their initial the dogs out of a and
everything is Spanish interesting you're
talking about the same disorder Joe's
talking about
I'm if is the same disorder but it's
like similar yeah it's kind of like in
passing I read or watched [ __ ] like this
and it's just nuts like I just remember
one that was like this person was
speaking Latin
and they just picked up the language and
I'm like that's some demonic [ __ ] dude
only demon speak Latin now you know no
one really speaks it anymore but demons
and like Oh pastors maybe like I was
like the consistent things like demons
definitely speed glad that's a fact we
know it's demon other thing you know
like every time you have like a
poltergeist or some kind of like what do
you call it exorcism right always
speaking Latin yeah they're not speaking
like straight English no they nip I want
a contemporary demon like I want someone
to come out and like using like slang
just like I'm talking I'm gonna kill you
as [ __ ] right now RN [ __ ] 12 leave me
it's [ __ ] noise that 12 it all
Annoying eyes demon but yeah so this
lady she um she says that her voice her
pitch is actually a lot lower now there
used to be she says that her voice is
actually kind of mousy before and like
very high pitch what she got possessed
my voice used to be higher pitch uh
softer out which one of my girlfriend's
is watching old video like when I first
started uploading on YouTube and she was
just like holy [ __ ] your voice got
deeper really no I know did you watch
that video yeah I did you hear it yeah
maybe I was more intimidated or
something so I was like trying to like
yeah that's how girls talk a lot like
online and stuff all right
well then just like trying to be bubbly
and stuff true was that bubbly before I
think I was always kind of like claiming
it was just a confidence thing maybe a
more comfortable from the camera so you
just speak more assertively my balls
just dropped it could be that I don't
know I'm still waiting for my balls to
drop my voice is so high your laughs
squeaky but yes I get hit in the head
man
yeah I have some accident what you know
what you want I got the line it'll help
you oh sure maybe I should pick up smoke
in there's a lot of really dangerous
ways to get to this and yeah yeah I feel
like it might happen it would go like
either Indiana like Bora oh my god I
would love
I'll be saying I would love it yeah like
ice mimic him so much that I feel like
that's what my body knows yeah very much
I would hate life I mean you just got a
move to like lit the way Nia or
something where they like for it speak
like Bora and try to pick up on a chick
they wouldn't want okay no just try it
just play it without me without the
kidnapped yeah hold up to kidnap oh I
forgot I saw something it was like
they're like all girls like guys with
like European accent so he goes and
starts their like an Eastern European
accent like a straight like Borat to the
girl that's like you what the [ __ ] yeah
why is that why is some accidents more
like oh yeah more suave and some others
aren't aren't like Chinese accents
aren't that aesthetics
hearted the song like the more I can
sound like a song and it's fluid and
like the octave is lower and more
soothing it's nice but if it's like
Vietnamese no shade but there's just
very high pitchy and like loud from
English right you're listening to it and
all of these languages that we like it's
symbol it's the most it's the Latin
family group there's Romance languages
right yes like so it's the most similar
so I think that's why it sounds good but
so we all speak American English that we
can't can we tell how sexy the American
accent is on the spectrum super sexy
super sexy I don't know you just right I
was like hell yeah I'm sexy yeah but
when we travel people always say our
accents a really dope and I'm like what
accent you're the one with accent [ __ ]
you go back to you came from
I'll try super defensive there hey man
you came here can you tell the
difference of trashy British and
high-class British because they all
sound classy to me yeah yeah there's
like 20 different British actually like
I've got some British friends and they
like this is a certain type of people
speak this way and it's just like the
same thing you know it's like local
whatever right
it all sounds classy to me like I could
tell the difference but I'm just like
ooh that sounds that bloody hell thank
you the weather you can understand that
yeah bloody [ __ ]
they say the peaky blinders accent was I
call it cockney accent they thought me
and my buddies from from England he's
like I can't watch that show the accents
are so like fake not real well yeah it's
just like so so much that he's like I
can't watch it it's like it's too
inaccurate and I'm like I think you're
being a little bit aren't they all the
actors British though but they I guess
they don't have that they don't have
that accent so maybe you'd be like you
know I was doing a consumption accent
yeah York or whatever yeah no but I was
like I feel like you're putting weight
it's a good show you should just watch
it regardless I think Americans they
can't tell actions as good as other
countries though well we're also not
around other countries like like let's
say Europe or Asia they're so close
together it's like we have like they all
watch our shows we don't really watch
this you know so when they put on an
accent but you color you're now watching
peaky blinders huh that's true you know
why cuz I'd be watching documentaries
and sometimes people need subtitles and
I'm like why they're just speaking
English it's like a slight accent I'm
like what the [ __ ] cuz you know how they
do that if they sound too [ __ ] up
Dennis Rodman talks I need focus I need
all sorts of his documented clears
throat he looked like he got big-ass
breath and he talks for like one hour
straight without letting anybody else
talk that's true do you think is any
other country as many different actions
as America does
you know like England's got a couple
different you know regional like the
amount that you have in America is like
you know you got your East Cossacks in
the of your boss and East Coast accent
you something
like some words yeah some words but like
where I'm from
even in New Jersey it's it's some
Central Jersey so it's neutral
South Jersey very distinct accent North
Jersey is your typical Italian you know
Jersey accent I'm in the middle so
certain words habit but it's such a
small state but it's influenced by
Philadelphia gives his accent to South
Jersey and New York gives its accent to
North Jersey
and they're wildly different accents
because everyone has really talked like
rocky uh no they it's like you ever hear
people be like all that you know been
gold they say weird like instead of
bagel they say bagel or like roaming
instead of room they're like I was a
apart on the rum
what's apartment in more language I mean
I say apartment apart like maybe like a
park like a part that would be a little
bit sort of Jersey apartment yeah and
then North Port Lavaca yeah coffee
yeah that's North Jersey north yeah but
it's like just even that and then you
have you know the Orleans where it's
like then you probably need subtitles
like that's like hard to understand and
then pass 12
it's like Canadians they say beg for bag
yeah baby shame bottle so they say it
properly bottle we see we say bottle I
be do ddle Canadian just sound like
people from Minnesota to me yeah that's
very similar yeah it's a Buddhist
there's another accent in America while
I'll be different
[Music]